Hey YouTubers it's Charlie! Huge news daredevil
season 2 just cast the punisher it's actually
Joe Bernthal from the walking dead, Shane
is the punisher my initial reaction is of
course Shane is the punisher that's what he
was on the walking dead that's totally his
character a lot of you guys asked me earlier
this year whenever they were getting ready
to premier daredevil it punisher whatever
ended universe because Marvel got the rights
back to him pretty recently Netflix feels
like the perfect place the character very
low pressure you know the problem with putting
him in a movie is is if it fails then they
have to wait like four or five years before they
try again just because it's such a bomb this
way he has Charlie Cox and the rest of the
supporting cast developing them through 13
hours of television in an ensemble just gives
them much more time to flesh out the character
way more than a two hour movie ever would was a
dozen urgent there on Netflix they can be
as violent as they want you just let me know
if you are unit do you feel like Netflix is
the perfect place for the punisher character
and everyone wants to see him do really well
in the Marvel cinematic universe and I think
that he could transition into the movies eventually
but I think Marvel needs time to build the
character out remember all the other versions
of the character we've seen before or from
other studios if any of you saw punisher war
zone it was a pretty crazy film the director
of that film is actually going to be directing
Arrow this season obviously a bit of a step
down in terms of violence but as I think it's
interesting what's going on with punisher
right now pop-culture if you haven't been
reading secret wars just cancel for spoilers
for punisher and then the first couple of
issues just because he is a really awesome
appearance you probably heard the battle world
it is just you don't OneWorld made from the
pieces of a bunch of different places in the
multi-verse of a bunch of different earths the
story the punisher appears in, he is like
the tether for Dr. strange's soul from another
universe so you get like Dr. strange punisher
the interesting thing about that is that Dr.
strange is really important to the defenders
which is obviously what all these Netflix
errors are building up to there's a lot of rumors
that Dr. strange will have a cameo in the
defenders I'm not going to hold my breath on that
because Benedict Cumberbatch is a really busy
man really a lot of the mysticism inside these
Netflix series is probably going to come from
the iron fist series just because that's the
the next best thing to Dr. strange that you
have a lot of his stories flow from mystical
place to either just in the same way that
Dr. strange's stories to in the context of
the daredevil series the punisher is actually
shown up in daredevil comics a lot of times
so the not bending Canon or anything like
that to bring him on a series Marvel's official
white paper on the character like that official
synopsis that they give is he's a vigilante
who aims to clean up New York City's Hells
kitchen by any means necessary no matter how
lethal the results that last bit is the important
part no matter how lethal his description
reads exactly like daredevils you know cleanup
Hells kitchen by any means necessary is just
of the punisher as that lethal modifier meaning
he's going to be killing a ton of people one of
my all-time favorite punisher moments was
actually from Marvel Civil War been a couple
years ago he E-base week he tried to help
out Captain America's team but they weren't
having any of it this is at the point when
things are gotten really bad to they needed
all the help they can get but they saw punisher
and there is like no you know what you're
just like a little too crazy for us so working
to take a hard pass punisher always works
best when he is is absolutely ridiculous but
not so ridiculous that he turns into Deadpool
Deadpool is is like a pure comic book character
that's I feel like even the Deadpool movies
going to like tone the character dad just
like a little bit because the essence of Deadpool
and is complete fancy like it's a completely
unrealistic character punisher feels much
more grounded in reality your psychopathic
hero walks around killing people in the name
of justice is not to walk around with his
severed head or anything like that although
he might sever a few heads daredevil season
two isn't supposed to premier till next year
him and is going to premier about the same
time season one premiered right before Captain
America Civil War comes out just in case you
guys want some deep cuts for good daredevil
punisher stories here a couple suggestions
you might be able to find most of these are
Marvel unlimited but there is child's play
that's a story from daredevil 183-184 it's
one of Frank Miller's older stories it is
a good example of Matt Murdock protecting villains
from Frank Castle I think a real WTF and season
to would be daredevil protecting Wilson Fisk
from punisher remember as of the end of season
one their bitter enemies so they that be just
a really fun twist or daredevils like yeah
you're the worst thing imaginable but you
don't deserve to be gunned down in cold blood
then there's daredevil versus punisher which
is like it its own separate comic book by
itself is daredevil and punisher separately
like on their own going after hammerhead in
the jackal while the kingpin is still stuck
in jail that we they're both pursuing those
villains on their own use using their own
methods punisher course wants to annihilate
them daredevil just wants to get them locked
up the end of class you get a lot of daredevil
fighting punisher which which I feel like
they're totally going to do the Netflix series
you can't have a really classic daredevil
versus punisher comic in not have a moment
like that on the TV series ultimately we have
to remember your punisher is a hero so is
much as he's going to be fighting daredevil
during the series they will help each other
I wouldn't be surprised if that's the case
when all the defenders meet each other you
know Luke Cage orifice Jessica Jones it's,
like the first avengers film whatever thorn
Ironman when added for a little bit no hard
feelings point break you got a mean swaying
before this news came along I was gonna do
it Jessica Jones video so I might push that
to later this week but just because punisher
is such a big deal I think tomorrow I'll do
like my top five punisher stories in the comics
so be sure to subscribe to get that If there are any punisher related videos that you guys want
just let me know in the comments and I almost
forgot my Marvel giveaways starts now
it 's just like my game of thrones giveaway
it's a $20 Amazon gift card all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on this video. I'll
announce the winner when I post by next
Marvel video. just because of that, too my normal
DC Flash Arrow videos will get pushed by little
bit but those are still happening this week. for
those of you that just can't stop thinking about
walking dead now that Shane is the punisher
I am going to be doing fear the walking dead
videos pretty soon so while you guys wait  for that stuff
to drop you can click here to learn all about
bullseye coming to daredevil season 2, he's
supposed to be one of the villains and you
can click here to learn all about legends
of tomorrow. thank you so much for watching,
everybody high five and I'll see you tonight!